Luke here at the outdoor boys YouTube
channel and me Tom and Nate we are
building the most epic cardboard Fork
[Applause]
[Music]
well everyone welcome to the outdoor
boys basement this is a little playroom
the boys like to hang out usually this
place is strewn with toys but I'm gonna
do a little surprise for the boys I want
to build an awesome cardboard for a
castle in fact and we're gonna see just
how insanely huge we can build this
thing so I've been planning to do this
project for about a year now and this
entire time I have been squirreling away
all the cardboard boxes we can get our
hands on our family orders a lot of
stuff on amazon.com so we got a lot of
boxes to use for this fort and I have
them right outside so let's bring them
in all right there we go
whoa oh you're up high so I need to
organize stuff pile up all the cardboard
get it as flat as can be and then we can
get started building
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
I love it
[Music]
[Music]
yeah buddy
no more digging your diaper off there we
go what are you guys think so far all
right got some reinforcements here
mackenzie family's got the hook-up bring
me some more cardboard boxes that's a
much needed artistic vision and manual
labor
that's structural right there this'll be
good like flooring
they got tube here big box we'll need
that damage on this
I appreciate the donations this is some
good cardboard here and we got well like
many of these projects this is turned
out to be a lot more time and energy
than I anticipated all right guys it's
day two of the cardboard Ford build
project we got a lot to do so we better
get crackin
[Music]
[Music]
so all the Amazon boxes have a number
they'll be like a 3 a 5 K 3 1 B 4 so I'm
going to put all the Amazon boxes in a
pile I'm gonna organize them by size and
shape buddy my tetris skills are coming
in handy right now
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
well things are coming along pretty nice
but I've got a lot of odd shaped boxes
left over and I need to try to make
something half decent looking with all
these leftovers let's see what we can
put together
[Music]
[Music]
poor thing
[Music]
well guys it's the final day of the
cardboard castle build and we're gonna
get this sucker done and I can't wait to
show the boys it's going to be awesome
gonna blow their minds all right now we
gotta get inside this thing and install
the electrical it's kind of cramped well
guys it took three days but I'm finally
done and look at this this is all the
cardboard I have leftover and after nine
rolls of duct tape this is all I've got
left
whoo so without further ado let me give
you the tour there she is folks 180
square feet 90 pounds of cardboard let
me give you the tour here so come across
the drawbridge and when you're safely
inside your castle you can pull up the
door okay so over here we've got the
gate keepers house with shingled roof
and comes in here and pops out a little
back entryway and on the other side we
have rampart and it goes in here and
goes down this way now over here we have
the Cathedral it's in the norman style
shingled roof shuttered windows and
spacious main entryway this is the
castle fireplace with many logs to keep
warm in the winter and here is the piece
de resistance our three storey tower
with Juliet balcony got a ladder here
for the kids to climb up and this is
strong enough to support their weight
this too they can climb up on here and
there's a little ladder back here
and is a nice little added touch I
strung a couple Christmas lights down in
here inside the rampart so the boys can
see what they're doing so we have
electricity in our cardboard fort I
think I can safely say this is the
biggest cardboard fort I've ever made
now this is for the absolute best part I
get to go get the boys and show them the
fort
let's go do that that's gonna be awesome
all right guys you ready go for it go
inside check it out oh I need to go
inside there you go buddy across the
drawbridge yeah it's all it should be
all safe you like that
[Music]
David where's the window you can stand
right up in that fig ketchup yeah it's
not even oh you guys know what we need
it we need hold on I'll be right back
sir Nathan you're a knight in the castle
you need your sword and shield there you
go buddy
Knights of the realm show me your
shields are you ready to protect the
castle from Dragons
[Music]
[Music]
well Knight
I hate to tell you this but I think you
just got locked out of your castle
hey guys would you like to camp out
overnight here in the cardboard for ya
let's sleep here you wanna do that let's
do that right Tom you got all your stuff
yeah nice jammies well guys thanks for
watching and we hope you enjoyed this
video I had a good time with our
cardboard for project if you guys would
like to see the videos where I should I
make these swords shields for the boys
check out the link in the description if
you'd like to see more videos from the
outdoor boys YouTube channel don't
forget to thanks for watching we hope
you guys enjoyed this video if you'd
like to see more great videos from the
outdoor voice youtube channel don't
forget to click Subscribe we put out new
videos every week and don't forget to
hit that Bell button so you'll get
notified when we put out another great
video